all right so this is BMO lost I love BMO
so naturally I really like this episode
yeah well we'll get to that in a second
so starts off BMO it's just do we know
what she's looking at she's looking
through a telescope but we don't see
it's looking upward right so do we know
it's just other worlds or galaxies or
whatever okay so at first I thought was
like a me buzzer or something but she
was looking like it wasn't like maybe in
the grass somewhere far I was looking up
so did you see no no but you saw what I
was pointing up or it was one up
redundant oh you're just leaving you the
open ass so so and then just a bird out
of nowhere comes grabs her heats of two
or other baby birds just gets up and
leaves comes across a bubble voice by
levar burton and they are taken
adventures they come across a giant ugly
as hell baby and they say I've always
said babies are ugly I was like that is
probably the best representation of what
babies look like to men like most men
would just look at a baby it's like I
know what you ladies have seen in this
life like this is just like an ugly tiny
sumo wrestler and it's just like um I
almost just maybe who's even bigger than
that yeah so he's even worse it's like
very rare I don't know it's like and
it's very very I see a baby where I'm
like oh ah that's the time I'm like but
and I know like you're not supposed to
say that but you said already so yeah so
it's probably okay but yeah there are
one two times a baby can look you but
it's like I haven't seen that Betty um
I'm sure my own tears but yeah they're I
don't know and your baby around him yeah
I never did
so but they eventually get the baby - to
the mother and they go home or they they
finally make it home and the bubble
feels so good that he has BMO to marry
him and she says yes and then Jake pops
the bubble we just lost our at that
point I mean we like how old laughing
because it was not expected I've got you
did - okay my I was watching from a
different angle and there was these -
and Jory was terrified she was like oh
my god what the hell just happened what
did you do and Doug was just like oh
those great just the reactions were
phenomenal
it was perfectly tight I mean they're
filling up his excitement the music's
going just hang a bubble and you just
see the finger come and it's just gone
in like one frame it would just look
like that and it's just the perfect
little delivery that like you said just
like an arrow just goes boom in your
heart but it's okay because he becomes
air and everywhere she goes he'll be
watching
no no more privacy every day she goes
into he'll already be there for the rest
of her days until she dies with Ted
Allen that was perfectly done because at
first I was really afraid cuz I was like
no they should have stopped at you know
the bubble being popped in think oh yeah
that is funny you sound like I was like
no stop don't let don't keep going and
because I felt a little bit a perfect
spot to end it but they kept going and
it was still funny it's like I sort of
tell myself I wonder if they were
originally gonna stop there but then the
censors are like yeah a little bit more
they knew they couldn't get past or
something but that's a good compromise
because that was pretty funny you know
the I will always be there watching you
for the rest of your days and you know
that's funny nothin and her gun is
really great so I I just wish they would
have like pulled in on her eyes or
something like that and then stopped
there before she said yay so it's a hole
watching you blow up and you don't see
any
actual expression it could be a happy or
sad or a terrified and then it cuts away
and that's it I sure like the yeah huge
JEA cuts it down a little bit so it's
not like creepy cuz I was even going
home because at first I was just so
traumatized I was like oh my god oh my
god oh my god and then and then the
creepy son I was like oh no that is no
sexy hit man
welcome to marriage where sexy hit men
do not exist
hey I'll be your sexy hit man you pour
that nice
what are you giving it sexy like anywho
so I lean so no beep BMO I always love I
I kid she's just too frickin cute I'll
hit Doug okay can we talk about that you
sexy like there's no sexy way for us to
do anything together oh nice so thanks
you slash fiction writers you've made my
wife happy
you saved our marriage so anywho um I
love BMO the only part where I was kind
of like all right this is kind of you
bring a baby into anything I think it's
kind of death that's what I said yeah no
I it's like this very few times I've
seen like you know uh-oh someone's got
to take care of her baby and it's been
really funny it's like three men and a
baby I hate that mr. bean up there so he
has to take care of the baby I hate I
mean it's just anything we had to take
care of a baby it's just not that funny
for me uh and I don't know I'm sure
there's something out there Dead Alive
I never thought I did it's one of Peter
Jackson's first movies he has to take
care of like some mutant baby zombie yes
but yeah so that part I was kinda like
yeah okay just get through it whatever
but yeah everything else I love the
bubble I love that you get in there live
Corsi Corsi is okay here we go yeah oh
oh this was a pure Jacksonville yeah I
always remember this counter who can
forget this cover that that's an
incredible coat in the UK it's called a
brain-dead let the us head will be
called brain-dead so okay cool sorry the
horrors coming up okay
so there that up dude if you have it or
maybe not maybe it sucks and they have
no idea what they're talking about but
sorry let's all be babies I could go
wrong zombie babies uh so yeah I really
I really liked it I loved that ending it
made me laugh very very hard uh how
about you Jason
that movie also has a priest that kicks
ass for the Lord will you talk about the
Imam lost okay I love that levar
Burton's in it second episode in a row
with a Star Trek next gen yeah yes you
know you love reading grey but she she
didn't have a crab a lost art okay you
know what though I kind of have to agree
yeah kind of
next jet you're full of crap I had no I
had more of a childhood connection to
Reading Rainbow than I ever did with
next-gen or any Star Trek for that
matter okay I like Star Trek but I had a
childhood connections meaning down a
book can take you anywhere but not on
the Starship Enterprise that's just the
starship metaphor actually no they've
had numerous books and comic books about
Star Trek so yes a book can take you on
the enterprise either one of them
falling apart yes read a book damn it
you just a movie on a book The Lorax
read a book no BMO lost vo is just a
character to begin with don't you cry
into my movies oh my god I'll give you
the books it's okay mimmo loss she's
super cute it's super cute
I liked it except for the baby the baby
felt like the baby has to go across the
bridge and it's just like it reminded me
of mystery dungeon how they all inducing
a little jump and discover anything fell
off and the babies like to turn fall
like without he was thinking about it
breaking the baby was kind of funny too
it's like that thousand Bella all I
could get out of it well when the bubble
has to save them it was like well maybe
I can bring sleep its attempt I like
that because it was like you didn't
expect it but once it happened it was
like okay this wait oh wait a minute
there's like some goat headed hunter
that guy started I liked that it was an
okay episode I enjoyed it but other than
like the ending for the most part it was
yeah like it was gonna say if it wasn't
BMO I probably would have gotten into it
as much but I'd like us I just think
she's like freaking adorable so what is
funny
OOP so this has to be one of my favorite
episodes ever like for serious ever that
ending that bubble and that and that
that connection between the two of them
going through it babe
it just I don't know what it is I love
BMO anyway this is one of my favorite
episodes ever well I like is by
comparison to other episode well like
we've already seen that LSP it's like
really hard for her to carry an episode
she's good for a few words here and
there but it sorry BMO a character I
never expected to ever become a major
player much alone now has two episodes
dedicated to her entirely and they're
both good I mean is there with you
they're not like phenomenal or anything
but this just she's so into everything
she's doing she's just so likable of the
dude it's like yeah how can you Agee not
get into it
he posed a character that can actually
carry an episode and carry
well enough like LSP needs other
characters to interact with innocence
like other characters you already know
BMO doesn't need characters you already
know because we already had the mystery
one where there's no interaction pretty
much with anyone else other than her own
cell and this one would a bubble and I
think it's really good writing when when
when one BMO tripped both of Doug and I
went oh I'm very I'm very OCD so I
looking at that crag throughout the
whole episode I'm just like I'm just
like take the screen out from another
one I believe oh I did love when he
wouldn't be mostly uh-huh my batteries
are all let me take somebody's like
goodbye mm-hmm
Jorgen was like I never heard you gasp
so much throughout it but so everything
maybe it's just hormones I don't know
what Lord Almighty this episode it's ya
know I like good good good episode what
say you
terrible I already talked okay just uh
yeah while you're cool snake away again
the next episode we're about to watch
will answer something that happened in a
past episode two men episode